[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le cette
fuite sport l'émission consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
tout de suite le sommaire de votre
magazine football en division excellence
l'équipe senior de montigny le
bretonneux a remporté le derby contre
son voisin maurepas une victoire qui
leur permet de sortir de la zone de
relégation le résumé du match dans cette
édition
foot us les templiers d'elancourt se
sont inclinés ce week-end à domicile
contre les mousquetaires de châtenay
malabry sur le score de 20 à 8
cinquième défaite en huit matches il
condamne les élans courtois rester en
deuxième division la saison prochaine
vous entendrez dans quelques minutes la
réaction du directeur sportif des
templiers fenech anderson raid des
alizés deux sportifs de bois d'arcy
veulent prendre le départ de cette
compétition 100 % féminine qui sont
organisées du 14 au 19 novembre en
martinique au programme cette épreuve du
trail du vtt canoë nous leur avons posé
trois questions
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football et la 16e journée du
championnat senior excellence bonne
opération pour montigny le bretonneux
dans la lutte pour le maintien lésigny
montain longtemps portées contre le 6e
du classement au mot repas à domicile 2
à 1 et s'offrent une bouffée d'oxygène
dans ce championnat le résumé du match
les images sont signés à nicolas
gombault montigny le bretonneux remporte
dans la douleur le derby contre maurepas
mené 1 à 0 sur leur pelouse à la
mi-temps lésigny montant se sont
arrachés en seconde période pour
égaliser marqué le but décisif dans les
dernières minutes de la partie par la
sentinelle koyka karamoko score final 2
buts 1 en bungee ac narbonne faux pas je
rate j'ai juste devant le but
alors heureusement que je rate pas aussi
mais bon voilà on essaie de faire les
choses pour le bien de l'équipe
on se concentre et on sait ce qu'il faut
faire cette performance a permis de
briser une série noire de trois ans sans
victoire de montigny le bretonneux
contre maurepas pour réaliser cet
exploit le staff de l'équipe avaient
étudié son adversaire du jour et avait
mis en place un plan de jeu on avait
décidé de pas pressé très haut
parce qu'on sait qu'ils aiment faire
partir d'assez bas nous aspire est donc
on avait décrété de descendre de n'est
pas sept blocs pardon du un peu plus bas
pour pouvoir les contrer et puis à mieux
prendre a manqué un petit peu de
justesse toute la première mi temps on
deuxième c'est un petit peu mieux qu'ils
ont baissé le pied au classement
montigny le bretonneux remonte à la 8e
place et comptent désormais quatre
points d'avancé sur la zone de
relégation
on sait qu'il reste encore deux places
pour pour descendre c'était que nous on
vient de monter donc on va arriver
l'humilité dans la division l'objectif
c'est le maintien on va essayer de se
maintenir plus rapidement possible tous
les matches sont durs à jouer pour jouer
tous les matchs sont joués à 200% moi
c'est comme ça que je vois les choses
les choses dans le football
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche 30 avril à
domicile contre les mureaux une équipe
qui lutte également pour sa survie en
excellence on continue à parler de
football la nouvelle est tombée à fin
2016 le santon l'enterrement
d'entraînement du paris saint germain va
quitter son traditionnel camp des loges
pour déménager à poissy nos confrères de
rmc sport ont pu se procurer des images
du futur projet installée à
l'intersection des autoroutes a13 à 14
la structure de 74
car comprendra dix terrains
d'entraînement centre médical un club
house des bâtiments administratifs un
stade de 5000 places et la salle
d'entraînement du pg handball
le centre sera opérationnel pour la
saison 2010 9 2020 on quitte à présent
le soccer pour parler de football
américain c'est désormais officiel les
templiers d'elancourt ne remonteront pas
dès cette saison en première division
conséquence d'une nouvelle défaite à
domicile contre les mousquetaires de
châtenay malabry sur le score de 20 à 8
au classement les landes courteau ne
peuvent plus rejoindre le deuxième est
vrai pour participer aux playoffs de fin
de saison
on écoute le directeur sportif des
templiers une grosse déception oui parce
que c'était l'objectif et qu'on a on a
travaillé dur pour ça on à la saison est
terminée mais derrière il ya eu huit
mois de travail compaq ont pas abouti à
l'objectif qu'on cherchait après au vu
de l'effectif qu'on avait on a un
effectif encore très jeune donc enfin
encore un peu l'expérience apprendre à
gérer des matchs et tu veux progresser
je pense qu'il leur manque pas mal de
football encore est bien moins qu'une
équipe aussi jeune c'est pas forcément
ce qu'il ya de plus mal de leur donner
le temps de grandir et et d'apprendre à
performer sport américain toujours en
baseball et cougar de montier bretons
ont concédé deux défaites sur leurs
terrains ce dimanche 23 avril leurs
bourreaux du jour le muc barracuda ce
baseball lésigny montain se sont
inclinés au stade jean maréchal 1 0 et 3
1 au classement les cougars gardent leur
cinquième place avec un bilan de 3
victoires en huit matches disputés
prochain match dimanche prochain sur le
terrain de pas réussi on passe au rugby
on jouait ce dimanche les 32e de finale
de fédérale 3 l'équipe senior de plaisir
jouer contre pontault combault l'ancien
club de l'entraîneur plaisir à genlis
retour qui lui a plutôt réussi puisque
son équipe s'est imposée dans la douleur
à l'extérieur 25 à 21
il faudra désormais réussir un grand
match au retour pour passer au tour
suivant et pourquoi pas viser la montée
en fédérale 2 sûrs
handball monti le bretonneux n'en finit
plus de gagner lésigny monteyne ont
enregistré leur sixième victoire
consécutive dans le championnat de
nationale 2 en dominant à domicile le
club l'as aulnoye le score 33 à 29
au classement les yvelinois sont
troisièmes à égalité avec le paris saint
germain et compte seulement cinq points
de retard sur le leader avec un bilan de
10 victoires 1 nul
et si les fêtes on continue à parler de
handball un tournoi une espèce était
organisée mercredi dernier à plaisir le
lycée à jean vilar de la commune
affrontés à cette occasion à lycées de
l'académie de paris un autre 2 créteil
l'école est une habituée de ce tournoi
puisqu'elle s'est déjà qualifiée en 2012
pour les championnats de france
la meilleure équipe cadette du
département tels réussi un nouvel
exploit la réponse dans ce reportage
le titre de champion inter académique de
handball s'est joué ce mercredi 19 avril
à plaisir l'association sportive du
lycée jean vilar recevait au gymnase
d'une école hassler les lycées de paris
et de montereau objectif décrocher une
qualification pour les championnats de
france unss
douze élèves plaisir à actuellement en
seconde et en première ont participé à
la compétition
c'est là le niveau il est moins élevé
qu'en club quand même mais il reste
quand même bon sur l'équipe de paris
nous on est un peu au dessus
physiquement aussi
mais sinon après ces attaques le mans
s'agit bien c'est assez important quand
même même si c'est un championnat qui
est moins fort que ce qu'on pratique en
club c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on
tient à coeur parce qu'on est des
compétiteurs et on veut absolument
gagner ce tournoi est aussi l'occasion
de mettre en pratique les deux heures de
cours dispensées chaque mercredi depuis
début septembre dans le lycée moi je
suis dans le questionnement je les fait
réfléchir sur le jeu je les fais
intervenir dans les temps morts
je les fais intervenir à la mi temps
pour avoir leurs ressentis savoir ce
qu'il faut changer et c'est pas c'est
pas moi qui donne toutes les
informations j'essaie de les fouler
mobilisés alors au sens tactique et
réfléchie du jeu pour qu'il y ait un
apprentissage pas
l'équipe de plaisir a finalement terminé
deuxième après sa défaite 23 9 contre le
lycée montereau un classement qui leur
permet d'accéder au championnat de
france unss
la compétition devrait se dérouler fin
mai ou juin
vous êtes sportif et vous trouvez aucun
partenaire pour faire un tennis ou bien
une partie de basketball dans votre
ville le reportage qui va suivre va
peut-être vous intéresser une
application mobile pour faire du sport à
plusieurs a été lancé le 15 avril
dernier derrière le projet deux bus en
pour toi ambitieux reportage d'anne leur
langue y est dit
ipsen berger démonstration de danse et
cocktails à gogo le tout dans une
ambiance de soirée les créateurs de
l'application wii sports n'ont pas fait
les choses à moitié pour son lancement
ce samedi 15 avril et les guérés l'un
des fondateurs de l'entreprise explique
son fonctionnement
c'est une application mobile qui me
permettrait de trouver un partenaire
sportif et malheureusement je n'ai rien
trouvé
et c'est de ce moment là je me suis dit
je vais créer applications sportives tu
vas me permettent de trouver un
partenaire sportif autour de moi à côté
tu y es moins qu'on pratique et peu
importe le sport que je veux dans un
premier temps wii sports sera testé en
ile de france et proposera tous les
types de sports pour lesquels il y aura
des recherches de partenaires ce soir là
toute l'assemblée a téléchargé l'appli
même commencé à l'utiliser plus forte
c'est là mon téléphone par l'emploi
je pense que demain je me refusais pour
transport d'un ornement il ya des
une course à saveurs d'ailleurs je serai
son usage reste gratuit pour les
particuliers en revanche côté
professionnel du sport il faut conclure
un partenariat avec l'application pour
pouvoir y figurer salle de sport
associations et clubs sportifs sont
intéressés cheka forme
on recherche beaucoup les bd particulier
comme ça qu'ils nous aident à justement
avoir plus de clients chez nous donc ça
peut nous rapporter vraiment beaucoup de
beaucoup de potentiel cinq jours après
son lancement en grande pompe on
retrouve le cofondateur de la société
yali guéret pour une partie de wii
sports organisés sur un terrain
multisports abus au cours leur de tirer
un premier bilan d premier jour de
l'application
on a eu déjà plus de 200 t chargement
tout sur android 2 et sur ios d'accord
voilà exactement c'est ce que j'avais
prévu
pour l'instant on sait que la tranche
d'âge et ans que 15 34 ans pour une
première phase ensuite bien évidemment
on compte toucher des personnes un peu
plus âgés on va dire magnifique c'est
j'attendais pas mieux ça comment super
bien l'entrepreneur vis dix mille
utilisateurs d'ici à trois mois dans le
département mais aussi ailleurs en
france on continue ce magazine par le
raid des alizés la compétition 100 %
féminine se déroulera du 14 au 19
novembre en martinique
soixante dix équipes composées chacune
de trois participantes vont prendre le
départ de l'épreuve
au programme du trail du vtt du canoë
dans les yvelines deux aventurières de
bois d'arcy se sont inscrits pour
participer à cette épreuve
nous leur avons posé à trois questions à
la sortie d'un entraînement
pour l' aventure humaine et pour
l'association que nous défendons qui est
l'association le cancer du sein
parlons-en
du coup cette année je pars avec ma
soeur et une voisine très proche en fait
elle m'a présenté déjà son projet à
l'année dernière j'avais suivi un peu à
ce qu'elle avait fait et puis cette
année elle me l'a proposé et donc j'y ai
réfléchi parce que ça demande réflexion
quand même de s'investir dans ce type de
projet et et puis je me suis décidé à le
faire puisque voilà j'ai une année
transitoire dans ma vie j'ai 40 ans
cette année
et là je me suis dit ma chouette il faut
que je prenne des challenge est donc
voilà je vous ai dit oui
courir forcément est le plus gros du
travail se fait dans le travail du
dénivelé est pour moi le kayak en
martinique il ya beaucoup de dénivelés
on sait pas dans quelles proportions et
on va en avoir mais c'est sûr y en aura
le sport là je me suis vraiment mise il
ya à peu près six mois
donc voilà donc c'est quand même un
sacré challenge une sacrée préparation
donc je pense voilà avoir le mental
déjà parce qu'au quotidien avec trois
enfants faut avoir du mental
et donc voilà je me dis voilà je me met
progressivement et puis avec des aides
de l'expérience ce site fleurs parce
qu'elle est très sportive donc du coup
elle m'apporte beaucoup
je la questionne et puis j'ai voilà je
questionne aussi autour de moi tous les
sportifs pour ce qui serait mieux pour
moi pour me préparer
à soixante dix équipes si on peut être
dans les 40 premières c'est bien mais
j'ai déjà participé l'année dernière et
j'ai eu des soucis donc j'ai pas pu
faire toutes les épreuves donc mon
objectif cette année c'est vraiment
finir toutes les épreuves
l'objectif ça va être deux quand même de
le terminer puisque moi je découvre ce
sport dont le terminer à 3 comme disait
flop
d'ailleurs le même objectif à lasser de
le terminer maintenant oui à la
meilleure place qu'on pourrait le faire
si on peut être voilà dans les mêmes 30
premiers j'irai ce serait chouette
et maintenant voilà on va c'est quand
même aussi découvrir dans un effort et
dans un cadre comme hors norme
les deux illinoise doivent trouver 8500
euros d'ici le 1er septembre pour le
moment les cette équipe baptisée mlm
smad mm sonara côté que 1500 euros on
leur souhaite évidemment bon courage
dans leur recherche
et on continue par de la boxe vous
pouvez noter dans cette date dans vos
agendas l'élan courtois marvin petit à
double champion de france défiera le 18
mai prochain au cirque d'hiver de paris
l'espagnol rero b santana pour la
ceinture de l'union européenne le combat
était initialement prévu en janvier
dernier mail ibérique avait annulé
l'affrontement deux jours avant pour
s'entraîner marvin petit parti en stage
en espagne comme on peut le voir sur ces
images
c'est la fin ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]